you ever find yourself watching TV or
reading a newspaper or listen to
politician and they start talking about
climate change fossil fuel emissions you
know carbon monoxide carbon dioxide you
know green house effect what is all this
stuff I don't even know what they're
talking about if you're somebody that's
there today I wanted to simplify this
whole climate change by digging up
different articles from both sides
those who say climate change is real and
those who say climate changes are myth
and a hoax and kind of laid out for you
to say well I'm kind of leaning towards
this side or this side so let's get
right into first I'm gonna talk about it
those who believe climate change is a
real danger those who think it's a hoax
what really started the entire
conversation with the greenhouse you
know effect and then the fossil fuel
leaders and then are there people on the
money side on the oil side that are kind
of causing us to not look at certain
research and in my final thought so let
me start off with who thinks climate
changes are dangerous so those who
believe it's a danger this is what
they're saying it's caused by mankind
you and I are causing it the opposite
argument to it is they're saying it's
been going on for a long time this is
nothing new
then there's folks that say global
warming will come and cause mass
extinction you're even hearing some
politicians saying we only have 12 years
left to live this is a very common thing
you're here on those who believe climate
change is real on the other side climate
methods it's natural politicians are
using this tactic of extinction as a
method of propaganda to put fear into
you and I too want to win a vote right
then some of the guys are saying
satellite measures in Antarctica are
showing that we're losing ice matter of
fact I want you to watch this 20 30
second clip of what's been happening to
Alaska this is a time-lapse camera over
an eight nine year period showing what's
happening to the ice there look no
matter what anybody says that visual
right there kind of gives you
perspective of what's going on by the
way there's a lot of different TED talks
that you can see or different videos to
see it all over the world not just in
Alaska that this is taking place too so
what is the argument to that what are
they gonna say about that that's proof
right there the argument is it's a cycle
this could be a simple cycle we're going
through today because I
saij happen every hundred thousand years
what can you do about Ice Age right I
mean there wasn't fossil fuel or
emissions or people going around doing
what they're doing at the time how do
you prevent an ice age when it took
place maybe we're going through that
right now matter of fact we had a mini
ice age from 1300 to 1800 in Europe and
northern America so maybe we're going
through something right now or what's
your argument to the snowball earth were
650 million years ago up to 710 million
years ago when the entire earth was
pretty much white because there was
snowball that's what they called it it
was all white it was so cold it was
minus 58 degrees Fahrenheit at the time
and scientists still today can't figure
out how that white went away where did
he'd come from if no one's doing if
you're saying it's mankind what made it
go away when there wasn't mankind there
right so that's the argument to that
point that's made next one Al Gore had
it all right argument he's a career
politician he's just trying to create
some more propaganda next one nine out
of the ten heat waves with most
fatalities have occurred since 2000
that's a fact right nine out of ten heat
waves have occurred since 2000 that
caused the most death a hundred and
twenty eight thousand eight eighty five
and by the way I don't know if you're
following this issue that's going on
right now with Venice we were in Venice
just a few months ago Venice right now
Venice Italy if you go to it here's what
the floods looking like on Venice if you
look at guardian that's Venice today so
what's the rebuttal to one hundred and
twenty eight thousand people of that I
mean since 2009 out of the ten worst
heat waves we've ever had
what's your rebuttal to it the rebuttal
is that's because we have more data
today than ever before we don't have
real data from a hundred years ago or
thousand years ago or 2000 you know
twenty thousand years ago that's today's
data so people can say that's the worst
we've ever had okay next one here's
another data from NASA showing that
climate change may be real in the last
50 years temperature around the world
has increased by 0.23 degrees Fahrenheit
per decade which means one degree
roughly per 50 years that is one degree
this is from NASA right what's the
rebuttal to that this is data that we
have for the last 50 years the rebuttal
is it's only one degrees in 50 years
what's the big deal about one degree in
50 years
last one is capitalists are protecting
their oil money that's all they're doing
this is their way of protecting their
oil money they don't care about the
future they don't care about their kids
they don't care about all this is why I
don't want to have kids because capitals
just want to protect themselves they're
not worried about anybody's kids or
grandkids the rebuttal is the
intergovernmental panel of climate
change is simply trying to shift power
by trying to strong-arm job creators so
they're just using data and they're
getting their facts wrong and they're
kind of spinning things they're not
really doing the right things so you may
be watching this right now saying Pat I
can't really figure you out are you
saying it there's a danger or you're
saying it's hoax because you know I
can't put you in any kind of a position
you sound like it on both sides the
entire purpose of this video is for you
to watch it and then from there go do
your own research don't take my word for
it or the politicians word or your
uncle's word go do your own due
diligence and don't just look at one
side don't just watch CNN or MSNBC or
just Fox look at both arguments so now
the argument here is that you and I are
causing global warming you and I are
causing the climate change to be a
danger us human beings so now how are we
causing this is the simple concept of
greenhouse effect let me explain this to
you
greenhouse effect is when you have a
greenhouse and you're growing plants or
you grown whatever you're grown in there
right it is set up in a way where the
Sun comes in and it the plants are
getting the Sun which they need to
nourish and grow but then the Sun is not
leaving and it's somewhat stained there
a little bit for it to grow and if the
glass is too thick then the heat waves
stayed there and it's not good for the
plants so there's a certain level of you
know thickness you need for the Sun to
leave for the heat to leave so doesn't
stay hopefully that makes sense to you
let me explain to in a different way so
here's the Sun this is the earth this is
the moon okay so the earth and the moon
are roughly 93 million miles away from
the Sun so you got 93 million miles
earth moon Sun 93 million miles right
which is about 150 million kilometers
for some of you guys in Europe right to
kind of put you in perspective so what's
your point your Pat here's what the
point is even though they're only 90 95
93 million miles away it's the same
number moon in the morning is roughly
212 degrees Fahrenheit
which means you and I would burn to
death within a minute were gone right
and at night it goes from 212 degrees
Fahrenheit on the moon to at night being
negative 338 which is you're gonna be a
popsicle at night and you're dead as
well so you and I cannot live on the
moon in the current conditions they have
now on the other side on earth the
temperature is roughly 57 to 61 degrees
Fahrenheit throughout the day right now
you got some highs you got some lows but
that's the average 57 or 61 which means
you and I can exist and we can live on
earth which is what you and I have been
doing for roughly 200,000 to 300,000
years your parents your grandparents all
the other folks that came before us
right so now you look at this data you
say Pat then why is it that even though
it we're only 93 million miles away why
is it that we can live on or but we
can't on moon it's because of that
atmosphere around and what that
atmosphere does is it allows the Sun
race to come in and it bounces off and
goes because it's the right thickness
that it has that remember the whole
glass then what we talked about that it
leaves but it keeps enough with the heat
here so you and I can survive and
because moon doesn't have that you
cannot live on the moon that's pretty
much what the argument is with the
ground greenhouse effect right if that
makes sense to you why are they saying
climate change and we are causing it
well that's leading to the carbon
dioxide which carbon dioxide is causing
this atmosphere to get thicker and the
thicker it gets the raise they cannot
bounce up so they're going in and
they're going boom boom boom and they're
coming back and poom poom-poom some of
them are leaving for Mom some of them
are going back in okay just kind of try
to get a visual for that so it's staying
here and that's why the temperatures
have been going up based on what NASA
said one degree in the last 50 plus
years right so now what does this mean
Pat here's what it means co2 carbon
dioxide what does it mean how does it
who produces carbon dioxide a few
different ways one of the ways is you
and I we produce it me you animals we
produce carbon dioxide in other ways
volcano eruption produces carbon dioxide
then it's the forest station which is
what the more trees we cut the higher
the carbon dioxide we have which means
again it's getting thicker and thicker
and thicker next one is the burning of
fossil fuels the more you burn fossil
fuels it's pretty impression and it's
keeping the heat within in here and the
last one is the land-use changes we're
cut
grass and we're turning into roads
properties etc etc said that is causing
the atmosphere to get thicker which is
causing a heatwave sustained if that
makes sense to you now we can go to the
next part which is 15 billion metric
tons of fossil fuel was consumed last
year 15 billion metric tons of fossil
fuel last year and who are the leaders
today number one today's China
twenty-seven point two one percent
number two is us at fourteen point five
eight India's number three at six point
eight two then you got Russia at four
point six eight and a half Japan at
three point three three percent at fifth
place right so now when you're listening
to this you're like well Pat I can I'm
watching this but based on what you're
saying this is kind of real this is
really taking place so what is the
argument that really gets them to say
that climate change isn't a danger
because if you look at politics
President George Bush Senior I believe
in the ad eight campaign went up there
and says this is really happening
global warming is happening we got to
pay attention we got to do something
about if anybody can do something about
it
America can right and then you fast
forward to around 2006 April 14th I
believe the former CEO of Exxon Mobil
Lee Raymond he started going out there
and this is rumors this is articles I
was written about it that he was funding
scientists to write articles and do
research saying climate change does not
really happen it's not really that
dangerous and it's not man-made it's not
caused by oil and by the way liyan data
began a four hundred million dollar
retirement package when he left April 14
2006 which is the largest ever at that
time for publicly traded company and
then there comes Rex Tillerson which is
the CEO after Lee Raymond and he ends up
striking a half a trillion dollar
contract with Russia to go and big in
the Arctic which is not something that's
happened in the past before and
obviously when that deal took place that
kind of benefits Russia because money's
gonna be made for ExxonMobil and Russia
and it just never happened before so it
was a very big deal for him with rex and
rex is also former believe CEO and
president of boy scouts himself and he
was involved in politics sec i mean he
did some stuff with trump as well they
had some issues with him and trump based
on what nikki Haley came out and said
that Rex wasn't a fan and he was a fan
and maybe he is maybe he's not there was
a lot of complex politically with him as
well but
that's some of the stuff with all
because you'll hear a lot of arguments
saying folks or running oil companies
ExxonMobil they don't care about you
know the safety of the we're going to
just they're just trying to make a lot
of money and they're trying to get some
big deals now all of this has caused
countries like China to spend seven
hundred eighty billion dollars in
renewable energy by 2030 that's what
their commitment is you got Bloomberg
who's not running for office he wants to
be President Democratic campaign you
know he's going out there to go up
against all these other guys he put
seventy million dollars into renewable
energy renewable industries at three
hundred billion dollar industry today
which attracts two different types of
people DOS that are coming in that
actually want to make a difference like
they want to correct an injustice but it
also attracts some people I said where I
can kind of come in and kind of you know
make some money here and and act like we
want to do the right thing but make some
money and then obviously it attracts the
politicians that kind of want to come
and regulate everything so the 300
billion dollar industry leads to
Northern Ireland government collapsed I
believe last year because of a one point
four billion dollar Green Deal scandal
that took place again there's a lot of
opportunity to make money so some come
in to make money some are actually
coming in to make a difference there was
a scandal that went there with that so
it attracts people like that Saudi
Arabia which has got the RAM Co Company
one and a half trillion dollar company
that I think just went public its
highest valuation company in the world
they put fifty billion dollars of money
into renewable energy and Facebook is
planning on running on fully on
renewable energy by 2020 hi so let me
give you my final thoughts on the
sensitive topic of climate change
because many of you may be watching this
right now I say Pat how could you even
say this you got the data here to show
it's happened you just talked about you
know the greenhouse effect you just
talked about oil funding all the sudden
what do you mean you may be a hoax or
this the debate is over with the debate
isn't over would this is my challenge
with this debate let me expect what it
is let's just say climate change is
caused by man and then the climate
change is also caused by mother nature
which is historically no you know six
ice ages one every hundred thousand
years the question I'm trying to get
answers the following question it's a
few questions one what percentage of
this is caused by mankind us what
percentage is Mother Nature are we
causing is thes are cause 1% 2% 5%
because some of the scientists saying oh
it's 70 percent us and we're gonna
I don't agree with that and then on the
other side some of the people are saying
well it's not even and we're not having
any effects on us what are you talking
about there's no I also don't agree with
that I do think there is an effect that
we're having at what percentage is what
I want to know second point when it
comes down to this I'm also not naive to
to not think about the fact that you
know cigarette companies nicotine
companies Philip Morris for many years
would hire scientists paying money on
the side saying hey give us some
research to show that you know nicotine
is actually good for you we know when
this happened with the movie thank you
for smoking you know the story about it
like hey yes and nicotine is good for
you it's not bad for you they pitched it
and we bought it milk it does a body
good milk there's a lot of different
research that's also not as good for
your sugar versus fat sugars not that
bad for you chocolate companies fat is
terrible for you we're learning fat is
actually not bad for you we just didn't
know about that one
all these scientists we didn't know
about it we're getting smarter so
there's also part of it that I get
funding scientists because there's two
different types of scientists there's no
that get involved and all of some money
buys about to go to a different place
make four times more get a bigger
funding and are those scientists that
truly want to do research to get the
right answers the scientists that are
trying to get the right answers my
challenge with them sometimes it's the
fact that they start speaking like
they're God in a hundred percent
accurate it's not all of them but a big
chunk of them are always only hanging
out with only people that agree with
them and sometimes to be in a setting
where you're only around people that
agree with you it's also not helping us
use your brain that you have the talent
that's been given to you to steer it and
push it a little bit to for you to get
frustrated want to go do more research
so the argument for me on both sides is
taking place like I lived in LA I looked
at the sky I looked at the clouds and it
was all black when I would drive down
the two freeway downtown or China you're
saying how it's of course we have we're
having some effect on climate change and
as somebody that's in the financial
industry to say 0.23% every 10 years
that's 1.15 degrees in 50 years
compound interest means in the next
hundred 200 300 years this can really
compound into bad news so we do need to
do some research about it I do know some
politicians love to use this as a
propaganda to say it's the end of the
world I also believe that rhetoric that
they're using that propaganda to give
votes and put fear in the younger
generation to get younger generation to
come into videos crying oh my gosh this
is what's going on this is
tactic that's been used for many many
years I'm just not the one that likes to
be nice so this is my request you this
might request you for those of you guys
that agree disagree and are neutral
you're saying well what is your request
to this Pat every time you get a climate
change topic that takes place on CNN Fox
knows whatever it's 26 minutes or it's
40 you know two minutes and it's
commercial breaks and break okay hold
that thought we're gonna come back to
you and it's typically filled with only
people that agree with each other or on
this side and it's 20 minutes how do you
and I learn about anything in 20 minutes
you know or you watch a documentary the
documentaries all on this side it's an
Al Gore did you know documentary or it's
all on this side it's a documentary
that's a hoax I would like to bring the
scientists who are for this the
photographer's that were there those
that say it's a hoax those that say it's
real
there are many scientists out there that
are you know gone and done decades of
research photographers I want to bring
you to my office my head my your
boardroom here we sit you down and we
have one side and the other side camera
crew three-hour debate we go I'm the
mediator I'm not the expert I'm the
mediator we go you have a computer you
have a screen you have a board to ride
on show whatever you want to show give
your argument if you're that strong
about your argument let's do this
together for three hours and let's let
the world look at this and then after
that the point isn't to win an argument
the point is to get to the truth so we
can do something about this this is not
about winning an election this affects
lives this affects our breathing this
affects our health so if the argument is
to get to the truth once we do that the
final topic I want to leave with if we
know this has happening what can we
truly do to in to change this and
prevent this from happening even if it's
by a small percentage because then the
innovators the entrepreneurs can see
this and say there's an opportunity for
me to correct an injustice and make
money I want to go out there and fix it
then it attracts the right entrepreneurs
to come in so if you are watching this
and you have certain scientists you want
to recommend or certain experts in this
area you want to recommend on both sides
of the aisles to come to the home office
you're in my boardroom for me to mediate
it send me a tweet at Patrick believe it
or send me a text at a number over here
the 31 Oh number with the name or if
you're the scientist
you're the expert yourself contact me
directly we'd love to invite you once we
have both people on both sides you know
people on both sides will and watch it
to do this here in our boardroom and
then if you watch this topic this video
you enjoyed it and you kind of want to
know a little bit more about the
political topics that are coming up
there's two other videos I want you to
watch one video I did it's on us Iran
relationship since I lived in Iran for
10 years many of you asked me to do a
video on the history of us in Iran I did
it this the video on the relationship
and it has to do with oil as well which
is kind of this video and the other
video that you may enjoy is one on
Social Security and how the long-term
effects of Social Security will be on
tax payers you and I the effects of it
if you want to get a little bit more
knowledgeable on that click on this
video and if you haven't subscribed to
this channel yet please do so thanks for
watching take care bye bye
[Music]